[Music]
this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the
ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america we're so glad you're
here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five as we talk about your life and your
money
all right here in front of you the
advice is free and some
say it's worth every penny you paid the
phone number triple eight eight
two five five two two five john's with
us in portland maine to start off this
hour
hey john what's up dave
uh how are you sir better than i deserve
man what's up with you
well dave we uh my wife my family and i
are debt free and ready to pay off our
house thanks to you
my friend and uh i want to know
if we should pay it off today and what
we should do with the rest of the
117 000 in cash we have right now
wow above what it takes to pay off the
house
no uh 27 000 is the mortgage on the
house
90 000 left okay all right
wow congratulations you've done very
well proud of you uh thank
thank you we've we've gone from where
you were a long time ago to where we are
now
so that's a lot of hard work thanks to
you i didn't do any of it you did it
um i just showed you how i'm proud of
you uh
so uh why have you not done it
well
we set the date for when our oldest son
youngest son graduates high school which
is two years from now
but as the number gets to a very
manageable number
uh our oldest son just graduated we
thought maybe we should just pay it off
now
what i want to do the other part of the
question is that that mortgage is a 2.75
percent
we we've paid it off like a 10-year loan
since we refinanced it
a while back so it'll be paid off in two
years
i no longer work as a bartender that i
used to do
i'm building uh rentals and tiny houses
is my goal
i want to put the money we have into
real estate and building these tiny
houses and renting them
so you're going to borrow money on your
home to put money into real estate and
tiny houses
say again you're going to borrow money
on your home to put money into
tiny real estate and houses so you're
saying pay off the house first
well you knew that before you called i
thought you'd tell me you told me 14
times thanks to you thanks to you thanks
to you that indicates that you know what
we teach right
yes sir i do i'm not making fun of you
i'm just i'm curious why you haven't
done it it just seems like a no-brainer
um i guess we've made decent money
more recently so we haven't always had
let's pretend much money
let's pretend you didn't have a mortgage
and you had 90 000 and you had 90 000
in the bank yes in order to have 117
would you go borrow 27
000 for two years at 2.7 i would never
borrow again what's the difference in
that in this discussion
i i guess i look at i i guess
i've had the mortgage i've had a payment
forever it just gives you a warm cuddly
feeling to have a mortgage
at 2.75 it doesn't give me a bad feeling
but it's
gonna go get you 270 000 one
no all right so we'll pay off the house
that's good because i want to pay off
the house
what do i do my point is you should have
done this like a year ago
well but i didn't i i like a buffer
dave i like a buffer because i don't
borrow money and okay
then you don't need my opinion you can
just do what you want to do it's okay
i'm not mad we're friends i think you're
awesome
but you're working you're working the
john plan and it's a great plan it's
working for you
but if you're on work a day plan you
would have paid off that house as soon
as you got an extra 27
000 above your 15 going into retirement
and above your kids college savings and
um
and then we go about the business of
building wealth and we use some of that
wealth in your case to build tiny houses
and buy real estate which is your dream
and you're going to do all of that with
cash because we don't borrow money and
you know
all of this john so
it's up to you though you get to choose
i don't but but
you know when you already know what my
opinion is you don't need to call and
ask me
it'll save you time i appreciate you
brother
chris is in boston massachusetts hey
chris what's up
mr ramsey thank you so much for taking
my call it's an honor i honor to speak
with you sir how can i help
well i'm wondering if you can help me
decide whether or not to keep or sell my
motorcycle
okay so um on baby step two
i started a little over two and a half
years ago um
started at 163 000 i'm down to 71 000
so it's going pretty good way to go well
but thank you but um you know now that
the finish line's getting closer i'm
just trying to figure out anything
extra i can do i already have three jobs
and the motorcycle is like my little
oasis but if i sell it i can probably
get you know about sixteen thousand
dollars for it or so
which would bump me up by about six
months and paying off my debt
and and you have a car i'll take it i
take it the motorcycle's a toy it's for
enjoyment
yes and what's your household income i
make about sixty six thousand dollars a
year
and what what is your car worth uh
it's a hooptie it's probably only worth
about three thousand dollars
so your motorcycle's worth five times
what your car is worth
yes that's pass backwards
yeah i got the bike before i found out
about that i know i know i'm just saying
that the net result is still there right
yeah i mean you're not doing anything
wrong i mean this is it's just a
it's a valid good question you've got so
um
it's completely up to you you're not out
of line on your numbers
okay you're going to be debt free inside
of two years
either way right yes it's about
22 months if i don't sell it and yeah
yeah and my rule of thumb is simply you
know
if it got you out of debt if it was
going to be three years and it got you
out of debt in two years
i would have done it because anything
over two years i start to i start to get
the quivers
i start to shake i want you i want you
out of there faster than that with your
gazelle intensity because dude you are
you are game on i mean you're working
every job you're not doing anything
you've got no life the only life you've
got it's a motorcycle occasionally but
you don't
have time to write it because all you do
is work and so you know you're
you're doing everything the way i did
and the way i teach people to do to get
yourself free right you want freedom
of course yeah so i don't think there's
anything wrong with keeping the bike and
there's nothing wrong with you saying
i'm going to accelerate this
someday soon i'll buy another bike
after i upgrade in car and uh
you know the total of everything with
motors and wheels should not be over
half your annual income you've probably
heard me say that it's too much invested
in things that go down in value
and bikes and cars and boats and seadoos
and
all the other crap we buy four-wheelers
with uh motors in them they all go down
in value
and golf carts yeah that's another one
and
um gotta have one of those to drive
around the hoa apparently
apparently the car won't work there but
the uh um
so yeah anyway this crap we all buy um
so yeah it's okay to keep it because
you're gonna be under two years
and what would i do if i woke up in your
shoes
ah i'd be on the bubble because i want
to be out of debt so fast but i also
hear you that it's your
it's your oasis my always is my boat if
it was my boat what would i do
i'd probably sell it if it was my boat
and get another boat later
and give me a little better car because
the thing's three times five times what
your car's worth
that's bothersome too this is the ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
chef
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsey show
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five the housing market is white
hot your house could be worth a lot more
today than it was just 20 minutes ago
and certainly when you bought it and
that means your old insurance policy
might not give you enough coverage
anymore
you see your insurance policy does not
automatically go up with the value of
your home
and so your agent has to
be doing like their job and stuff and
call you
and like do stuff like they're supposed
to do and raise the coverage to match
the actual value
however they have an entire filing
cabinet full of people like you and
they might not be thinking of you it's
possible
it could happen do you hear the sarcasm
i hope so so what you need to do is you
need to go to one of our endorsed local
providers and you need to go ahead and
shop your homeowners insurance it's a
really good time to do it anyway
these are independent insurance agents
which means they shop among a gazillion
different companies
and get you the right coverage at the
right
price in your particular situation
typical person saves about
700 bucks when they move their house and
their cars over to an independent agent
from one of what we call captive agents
in the market meaning they can only sell
for
one company and you know who i'm talking
about stay farm
okay yeah and so forth stuff like that
right excuse me i've got allergies and
so
to find a trusted insurance pro find out
the right coverage go to
ramseysolutions.com
check and search for home insurance and
we'll get you connected with one of our
elps
quickly and easily ryan is with us
ryan's in knoxville hey ryan what's up
hello how's it going dave better than i
deserve how can i help
yeah it's a pleasure and an honor to
speak with you and we greatly appreciate
your teachings
thank you so much our life i'm honored
how can we help
okay so we're in well we're just trying
to get it clear we're
bs uh three and uh
we just sold a business and a house and
we're about to get
an inheritance of some money and we're
trying to see if we
should pay off our home lots of piles of
money well i thought you sold your home
yes sir
or you sold a house not your home we
sold a house to buy a new house
okay so what do you owe on your current
home that you're asking about paying off
100 approximately 170. cool and the
inheritance and the business sale and
how much is the inheritance
uh it'll be just about two hundred
thousand after the sale
okay what should you get from the sale
of the business
uh what the sale of the business plus
the house that we sold
right because okay we had money we we
took a loan
you know we didn't pay off the house a
week so in total what we have
uh after um
emergency fund we have 279
that's from all three sources the sale
the business the house and the
inheritance
no two hundred's not at these they sell
the house we haven't collected yet so
that's not part of 279.
okay and and again your mortgage balance
was 170 right
correct okay and uh yeah i'd rather
check today and be debt-free how old are
you
40. god you're going to be so rich
listen dude seriously seriously i'm not
i'm not being sarcastic you take
what's your freaking house plan a couple
of grand not even
yeah so if you take a couple grand a
month since you don't have a house
payment anymore and you stick that
automatically into a mutual fund
you understand in 20 years how much
money that is it's millions of dollars
just just by paying yourself a house
payments to those goobs in new york
correct yeah see you bank of america
out of here countrywide correct yeah
we'd be ryan wide this is awesome way to
go man
exactly yeah we're stoked you're 40
years old
freaking pay for house what's this house
worth
uh we 319. yeah and you got a paid for
house and you got a hundred thousand
dollars in the bank and you got more
coming from the sale of the other house
correct and i'm gonna be you know
working and bringing in more money as
well
yeah well i mean we're gonna retire on
this but it sure does put you if you
keep working and investing and
saving and enjoying and being generous
and putting your kids through school and
paying cash you don't you you've
completely changed your freaking life
man
you are gonna be a baby steps
millionaire you're on your way
i hope so proud of you man get after it
do it today
write the check be done go out in the
backyard take your shoes off walk around
the grass feels different when it's
yours
i'm just saying it changes everything
this is more than just math boys and
girls
when you don't owe anyone anything
let me say that again you need to
breathe that in america
sally may done got her eviction notice
master card is no longer in charge
american is no longer distressed
you follow me here there's no stinking
car payment
you don't have a house payment
you walk in on monday morning and the
ball starts going
you just start walking off where are you
going
i don't have any payments i don't put up
with your crap anymore
it changes your decision-making it
changes your relationships
it changes your future it changes your
family tree
right what ryan has done with his family
and with the help of a small inheritance
and by being diligent up to 40 years old
and being smart
he wasn't smart all the time none of us
are i've done stupid zeros on the end
but this guy's
he's a freaking hero man we're talking
to a future millionaire right there
and that's not hyperbole that's freaking
math
all because he decided he wasn't going
to live normal anymore because normal
sucks in this country
you don't want to be normal normally
you're putting up with a toxic work
environment because you have to pay the
bills
normal is you put up with customers when
you own your own business you don't have
to let me tell you what's fun
firing an irrational customer that's
fun you don't talk to my people that
work here that way i'll fire your butt
give you your money back and take you
out of our database
you don't get to be a butt we don't pay
our people to put up with butts
we pay our people to help people that
are hurting but you don't get to be a
butt
it's different in it you get a whole
different sense of power a whole simple
different sense of direction
when you don't have any stinking
payments this is the borrower is
slave to the lender when a slave is set
free it's not
merely economics it's not merely
mathematics
it's choices and margin
and future it's everything on the list
chases us chase is in san francisco hi
chase how are you
i'm good i woke up clean and sober so
i'm grateful for that
that's good news how long you been dry
bud
uh about a year and a half good for you
what are you off of
thank you uh methamphetamines oh
tough one you're a you're you're a
strong dude man
a year and a half clean on meth man
that's strong
that is one seriously tough one to kick
good for you i'm proud of you
you got some good people in your life it
sounds like
yeah intervention by my mom and my
brother i love it
love a good family yeah how can i be a
part of your
story because you got a wonderful story
thank you i appreciate it um well ever
since i've gotten clean and sober
i got a really good job for me you know
i'm used to making twenty thousand a
year
um this year i'm on track to make eighty
thousand um
wow when i got my job i
i saw cars and i got sucked into
the shiny objects and i pulled out a car
loan
yeah then i started listening to you
right after that now i ruined everything
yeah yeah i ruined everything uh
so i have about 18 000 saved
um that i've saved in about six months
and i owe about 22 i think 24 with the
warranty if i cancel the warranty
22 i'm wondering i have 60
000 in student loan debt i'm wondering
if i should uh
sell the car back pay off the negative
equity
i think it's about 3 500 and then buy a
little beater
yes or if i should just add it to my
snowball
i would i would sell that car back and
because i think it's part of your
healing overall
this is a this is a great part of your
plan you're now addressing the realities
that are left over
from the addiction and you're doing a
great job with it i'm going to help you
i'm going to put you in the ramsey plus
once you go through financial peace
university
usually every dollar app i'm going to
pay for all of it free to you because we
are
we are so proud of you you're inspiring
you stay dry buddy
you stick with it man this is the ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
eric and rachel are with us hey guys how
are you
hi dave hi dave good to see you good to
see you guys where do you all live
uh we're from boise idaho oh that's a
bit of a hall to nashville
yeah well welcome all the way over to
the other side of the world good to have
you and all the way over here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off
we've paid off uh 137
000 good for you and how long did this
take
it took 30 months wow and your range of
income during that two and a half years
uh our lowest range was 121
000 and our highest range was 148 000.
good what do you guys do for a living so
i work for boise state's mba programs
go broncos yeah and uh i'm an electrical
engineer
oh very good cool and what kind of debt
was the 137
most of it was in a house a house and uh
you paid off your house
yes i'm looking at weird people very
weird people how old are you
i'm 30. yeah and i'm 28. and you pay for
a
house
and paid for houses thank you yeah
luckily we bought before the market went
crazy yeah
yeah luck didn't have nothing to do with
it you guys are on it man
look at you i love it what's this house
worth well
now do we just check the other day it's
worth around uh 170
or 370 000.
and you're 30 years old and it's paid
for that's right and you'll have a
payment in the world no
thinking weird y'all are so weird i love
you
you're amazing all right tell me this
story what in the world decide made you
decide you could pay off your house
before you're 30.
do you want me to start yeah go ahead so
it kind of started when we were
dating actually um i was coordinating a
financial peace class oh there we go
yeah and i had just started dating
dating this guy
and i was like this can't go anywhere
serious
if you're not on this plan oh so oh a
deal breaker right out of the gate
yeah i asked him to pray about taking
the class and you could tell he was
hesitant because he's an engineer
yeah he knows math you know he knows
math he doesn't
need to be told how to you know save
money so anyways
he prayed about it and he ended up
coming obviously wow
and um that was kind of the start of
eric i'm just saying that was a good
choice that's all i'm saying
i agree it has nothing to do with the
class has to do with what you got out of
the deal here that's right okay
yeah and he did a really great job he he
paid off the most debt in that
in that class and i was like he's a
keeper
he's a keeper yeah yeah so through that
process you can go ahead yeah i was a uh
starting off like you said dave i was a
little prideful she asked me about it
and i thought you know
talking to a guy i've never heard of you
before so she was telling me there's a
guy who can teach you how to save money
and i thought you know i know how to
save ninety dollars right now i don't go
to the class
you are the first one that has ever said
that yeah
but i was like it's worth it yeah
thankfully god uh he softened my heart
and
uh got rid of that pride and i'm so glad
that i was able to take your course
so how long end of the course after you
can tell the truth here we're friends
it's okay
uh it won't hurt my feelings because i
would have done exactly the same thing
you did except i might have never gone i
might have been too proud to
ever go but uh uh but the
uh how long are they how many classes in
before you went
you know this is probably worth it
well three four five i think it was
about the third class in
yeah uh we i we got your book and then i
think
um we were going through the class and i
thought it was taking a little long so
i pretty much just read your book all
night and then
after doing that i realized okay there's
some there's some good truth to this
stuff so
okay there's a process here i can plug
into because the engineers are process
guys right yeah i mean exactly
once you see the process the baby steps
you go oh game on okay
yeah all right good for you guys very
cool and how long you've been married
uh we actually just uh celebrated our
three year anniversary
awesome so three you get married and two
and a half years
into the three years or really almost
immediately you dive in on the debt and
let's pay off the house yeah did one of
you already have the house or did you
buy the house shortly after marriage
yeah i had i bought it shortly after
after moving out to boise and then
okay rachel so you had the house and the
debt yes
and rachel had the class yep i didn't
have any debt and that's why i was kind
of like
i need to find somebody who can get on a
plan with me like i don't care if he has
that
but he at least needs to be able to get
on a plan so we can work
on this as a team okay now that's that's
the best dating advice there isn't we
don't tell people not to date someone
because they have debt but i need some
say that again i need someone who would
get on a plan
yeah i need with me exactly yeah i
needed somebody who was able to say yeah
i'm a team player and i can get on the
same
page with you with you on this because
it's important to you but
i mean you didn't need to not have any
he just needed to be a team player
there you go man i love it that's
exactly how we teach people
and that's very mature very smart good
boundaries
not manipulative nothing there nothing
weird going on there like
you have to get out of dinner i won't
get you you know
dave ramsey does not say that he says
exactly what you say so that's beautiful
i love it i'm so proud of you guys
so who are your biggest cheerleaders
well so
honestly each other we kind of uh
definitely helped each other out a lot
but uh i would say
you were fought a lot yeah it was hard
getting on the same page really
it was yeah what did you fight about
well we had
we had just gotten married and we you
know we hadn't lived together before we
got married and
you know he's an engineer and i'm a free
spirit and it was like we were speaking
different languages at first
so actually you had the budget fights
then and everything
when you sit down to do the budget
you're arguing yeah so for me i was like
oh
you know let's just budget to the dollar
it's not a big deal if it's to the cent
and he was just like
no we need to count every penny oh
really through the penny
yeah to the penny wow and i was just
nerd and i'm not
i'm a dollar guys that's okay wow yeah
so i mean there were those fights but
now we don't fight is there a particular
item or situation that
one of you wanted to do the other one
didn't want to do that you remember the
big fight
um one of the big ones uh near the end
there i got a second job
so i was working full-time and then
working nights
to help kind of knock some of this stuff
out a little bit faster and obviously
that was kind of a
it was a strain on on both of us for a
little bit yeah he would work
at the technology company he works at
from about nine
two so what was the fight you didn't
want him doing that no i wanted him to
do that it just
felt like it was too intense i'm like we
already make a really good income can
you just stay
here with me and okay yeah and look at
what i've done i've created a monster
yeah yeah he works all the time that's
exactly what happened i told his mom i
was just like i was the one that started
him on this journey and he's the one
that's the most intense
i don't know what happened yeah well
exactly
be careful if you activate a good nerd
we know how to do it man we nerds we get
her done
give me a goal i'll go baby i love it
good for y'all that's
i like that that's smart and that's
that's real world stuff that's how it
really happens
yeah so the good news is you're free
how's it feel now
it it feels great to be to be free yeah
um
we're actually kind of uh feels a little
empty we got to figure out our next
next big step next big thing to go to go
tackle yeah it felt really good at first
and now we're just like this is kind of
a lifestyle for us as weird as it sounds
we really
enjoyed being on the same team and
having money goals and we're like okay
what's next what does this
look like and so it feels really good
you set your two goals
uh and put them on a spreadsheet and and
uh one is generosity
a level of generosity what do you want
to do i did that it helped me i want to
give away this much
yeah by this time and whatever it is you
figure it out
and then the other is uh go ahead and
back out when you're going to be a
millionaire
your baby when you're going to be a baby
steps a millionaire and start aiming at
that and that that gives you something
to aim at and you don't have to go crazy
about it you get to have a life you
don't have to work till midnight you
have to do all that stuff
right but we're just being intentional
now and working together you still want
to have that feel of being in the
harness together
and that's what you're saying and that's
very very wise way to go
thank you way to go what do you tell
people quickly the reason or the thing
you do to get out of debt is
freedom just being able to like you were
just saying earlier if your boss comes
in one day and
you're just not having it you know you
don't have to have that stress of paying
bills and you know
you're free to do what you want kind of
walk away and you get to be in charge
not
not the credit cards yeah and i would
say get on a budget
make sure you're on the same team and
then tithing was huge for us we had so
much money pouring in
during 2020 and it could only be
explained by god
yeah i mean there's so much blessing
yeah so many blessings that came from
tithing and
i think that's a huge part we got a copy
of the legacy journey that's your next
chapter in your story to be baby steps
millionaires you're on your way
and we've got a copy of the total money
makeover for your giveaway and start
someone on their journey thank you for
leading the class
yeah and uh thank you for leading uh the
most important
people you've ever had in the class his
name's eric yeah good job
137 000 paid off 30 months that's house
and everything they're not even 30 years
old 121 to 148 thousand dollar income
count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three
[Music]
couple of weirdos i love it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
thanks for joining us america this is
the ramsey show aaron is with us in new
hampshire hi aaron how are you
i'm doing well dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up in your world
he said dave i had a question for you um
about baby step two i'm currently
in the moment about to move into
apartment next month so i'm currently
pausing
um but i actually had a dream about
asking you this question i wanted to see
what your actual answer was
so i make forty seven and a half
thousand dollars a year
and on my car i owe fourteen thousand
and my student loan i owe about seven
and a half
now typically in the baby steps i know
that i would usually do
seven and a half first and the fourteen
but my company i work for
pays for my student loans i just have to
make an extra payment with it
um my student loan payment right now
will be about 30 bucks a month
and so part of me thinking why not just
tackle out the car
and just have the company pay the 166
and i just pay the 30 until it's paid
off
i just want to get your thoughts on that
that'd be okay yeah okay but here's the
thing
if you switch all we're doing switching
them that's all we're not going to slow
down
so you're going to put all the money you
can find on your car until it's gone
and then even though your company pays
the student loans you're still going to
put all the money you can find on the
student loan until it's gone
so the only advantage we're getting is
the number of months it takes you to pay
off your car
you're going to get some money out of
your company but that's all
so how fast you're going to pay off your
car
um my car will be paid off probably in
the next couple months i have about ten
thousand the bank i'll probably have
around
by the time i get there it'll probably
be around like thirteen and a half
to like thirteen thousand something i'm
sorry wait a minute
i'm sorry let's start again because you
you said you were doing the baby steps
and i got confused
okay so um the baby steps are baby step
one's a thousand dollars
any other money you have goes on your
smallest debt
and you work your debts off smallest to
largest in baby step
two and so your car balance is what
again
it is fourteen thousand okay so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna have a
four thousand dollar car balance when
you get off the phone
or actually a five because you need to
keep one thousand in your account
you said you had ten in the bank right i
do yeah sorry i i didn't clarify this
piece my bad um
because i'm moving into an apartment and
i i have an idea what the expenses look
like but i'm currently
pausing on baby step two oh you did say
that you did say that that's why the
money is there because you're paused
correct okay okay then i won't be such a
smart ankle
okay don't worry sorry about that
all right so um uh so all uh
so okay yeah let's do that now when you
finish
your move any money that's left above a
thousand goes on whichever debt is
remaining agreed
agreed because you push play again yes
okay now once you're doing that then
when the car is paid off then you attack
the student loan with the same
vengeance that you would have even if
your company wasn't paying it i don't
want to use your company money as an
excuse to stay in debt
longer instead we're gonna use your
company money as a way to get out
faster but that only works if you put
the same amount on the debts you would
have and you should be debt-free in one
year
i agree okay um so really at the end of
the day what we're actually going to end
up getting out of this company
is about 1500 bucks
that's yeah that's about right um a
quick another quick question on baby
step 2 that i
wasn't sure about is when i pay off when
i'm paying off the debt
is it okay just to pile up the cash and
then pay it off in one check or does it
make sense you just keep throwing extra
payments and then
it's better off to pay the extra
payments because both of these are on
what's called
simple interest and whatever your
interest rate
is on your debts is larger than the
interest rate you would get in savings
and you're getting credit for the day
you send it once a month you can't get a
daily credit but once a month
is compounded i see
so it works out better you're doing
really good here's what the good news
about your situation is aaron
you're really really thinking about this
you're really analyzing it
and you're paying attention the reason
most people are broke is
they don't pay attention they don't have
any idea what's going on
and you've got what's known as a clue so
you're looking for all these nuanced
little answers down inside the program
and that means that you really are
dialed in
and that's a cool thing i'm so proud of
you you're gonna do great
sam is with us in albany new york hey
sam how are you
hey what's going on dave i'm doing well
how are you doing better than i deserve
how can i help you
all right uh so double question well a
question
about the current housing market and
how much would be appropriate to spend
on a house
based on my income so
i currently am making around 14 to 1600
net every week and
i am planning on getting engaged shortly
and so i would like to purchase the
house so i don't know if this is an
appropriate time to do that or if i
should wait
six months seven months and then do it
do you have any debt no that's free good
you got your emergency fund in place of
three to six months of expenses
yeah it did okay well what we tell folks
is to never buy a home that is more than
a fourth
of your take-home pay on a 15-year
fixed and so that puts you at about a
fifteen hundred dollar house payment
on a fifteen year fixed that's about
what you can afford now your down
payment of course is
how much you save between now and then
add to that equation
you're getting married i'm okay if you
wait till a year after you're married
um actually there's a lot of wisdom in
that it takes about a year of being
married to know how close to your
mother-in-law to buy
okay you kind of got to get to know your
wife because the problem with buying a
house before you're married is
you will discover after you got married
that you bought the wrong house because
she will tell you
yes sir so that can happen i mean it's
happened before
all the guys all the old guys are
laughing right now so uh
yeah but the uh uh you know so i mean
it's
it's up to you you could you can buy but
i would have her
uh not make the decision but be very
involved in the selection so you don't
have to rebuy later
and i'm not gonna do any of this out of
a panic because i'm worried about this
real estate market this real estate
market's crazy
but here's the thing real estate is not
a short play it's a long play
here's what i mean okay how old are you
24. good for you okay when i was
the house that i bought when i was 24
uh was 52 000 today it would sell for
a half a million
[Laughter]
okay i'm 60 i'm 60. so what's the point
of that the point of that is
and by the way the real estate market
was quite hot when i bought that house
it was crazy people were just going nuts
interest rates were coming down after
having been really high
and everybody was just jumping on
anything that moved it was kind of a
little bit like now
right now it's hotter but uh point being
that all of this stuff
measures out and mellows out given a
little given a couple of decades here or
there
and so you're probably not going to be
in the house you buy that long anyway 5
or 10 years
on average and uh and you're gonna you
know so if you wait a year to buy it and
it goes up some
it's gonna go up more between now and
the time you're old like me
so you got plenty of time dude um so
there's nothing
don't ever get house fever like oh god
if we don't buy a house we're going to
be priced out of the market
i mean you know yeah if you don't buy a
house for 60 years you'll be priced out
of the market but if you don't buy a
house for two years you're not gonna be
priced out of the market
that doesn't happen because the markets
come and go they soften they get better
they get stronger back and forth and
over the scope of your life you're going
to see a lot of interesting stuff with
real estate but it's not a short
term play it's uh very difficult to make
money on real estate in the short term
but you can almost always make money on
real estate in the long play
it's a it's man you do a decade play
with real estate you can really set
yourself up for some
serious money very nice very nice
great job man congratulations on the
upcoming engagement hang on i'm gonna
send you a copy the total money makeover
for you to
read through with your new bride nine
million people have
and so you should too hang on
uh open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
that's what we do here we talk about
getting you out of debt
in the shortest possible time and it's
not just about getting out of debt it's
by getting out of debt so that you can
be outrageously generous
it's about getting out of debt so that
you change your family tree
it's about getting control because if
you can control your spending you're
controlling almost every aspect of your
life
because it all flows through your
spending just about money's not
important at all what it does
oh when it puts food on the table and
shoes on your kids
it's really important so what it does is
important
the money itself it really doesn't
matter so it's all about control
it's all about growing up and it's all
about long-term thinking and maturity
and we'll help you do that it's what
we've done for 30 years this is the
[Music]
ramsey
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america open phones at triple
eight eight
two five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five
johnny is with us in atlanta hi tony how
are you
hey i'm good how are you dave better
than i deserve how can i help
okay so there's a lot of meat this but
let me just get right into it so
i am 48 years old i'm on baby step
number two i've only got five thousand
dollars until i'm debt free and it's
credit card debt
so i'm working on that good now
i am on social security death
benefit income and basically
on that income it says that i can only
make a certain amount
a year which i believe it's like 19 700
or something
um before they start you know taking
away from me from what i've made so it's
kind of been hard for me to get anything
other than a part-time job but i have
had them
now i will tell you that um
due to coded my doctor took me out
because i was high-risk
but i did get released last month for
my uh sort of you know to get really to
go back to work here's the pickle i
meant
i've been apartment living for eight
years my daughter is 14
or will be 14 years old in november and
when she's 16 she has expressed to me
that she does want to
have a job so i do want to
help her and aid her in getting a car
for her
however i would also like to have a home
i'm kind of stuck i can't do both
because i just
i'm not able to afford to do those but i
want to know which one to do
so your husband passed away and you have
a social security death benefit from his
being deceased that's correct how long
ago
uh he passed in 2007. i'm sorry
okay um
i am not you so you're telling me that
on a death benefit from a deceased
spouse they stop that if your income
gets too high are you sure
that doesn't sound right i bet i last
not last year so what is the death
benefit how much do you get
i get 935 for my portion and i get 935
for her point
i'm 100 sure it does not affect her
portion
it does it does not affect your portion
it will affect my portion when you're
so what it's ten thousand dollars a year
girl go have a life screw the government
well and that's what i'm trying to
figure out you're sitting around for ten
thousand dollars a year handcuffed when
you could go have a life
yeah well i i did that i actually went
out and got a food plan
no you need like a you're 48 freaking
years old there's nothing wrong with you
you need like what's on
full-time gone get it go get it girl
career go make you 60 80 100 000
and flip your pinky towards washington
as you do it
i did that actually a year and a half
ago and then i got stepped
up by them taking away i think it was
130
each month who gives a crap about 130
dollars if you're making
well 80. not able to make 80 because i
am even even though i've went to high
school
i am not um a high school i'm sorry even
though i went to college i am not a
college graduate
so what so lots of non-college graduates
make 80. yeah i talked to one last week
made 300 selling real estate
i'm trying to find that job that will
put me over
honey it don't take much this is a
squirrel bar this is a low bar it's 10
grand
squirrel can get over this bar it's low
it's way down there low like it's not
even knee high
it's ankle high yeah
let me tell you let me tell you okay
let's stop just a second all right
i'm gonna tell you what i think i'm
hearing and you can correct me and i'll
be happy to be corrected but i think
when your husband passed away like for
most people
it was devastating
and you and your daughter have clung
onto each other
and grieved and hurt from this
and mixed in with that you didn't think
you were valuable because you didn't get
a
college degree which is not true by the
way that's a lie from the pit of hell
and the second thing is you lost some of
your confidence
when he left yeah
and now you've set your value down at
ten thousand dollars and i'm sitting
here saying
honey your value's a lot higher than ten
thousand dollars
i believe in you like way more than you
believe in you and i've only talked to
you one minute
it's been hard i know that's what i'm
hearing i'm hearing some pain
in there am i missing that no you're not
missing it
yeah so you were you were 42 years old
and your husband died right or 40 years
old
yeah how did he pass away
he it was a combo they don't know what
it got him first it was either
um lung cancer or cirrhosis oh my gosh
yeah oh my god and that was another
situation yeah there's a situation that
goes with that for sure
yeah yeah so there's a lot of pain a lot
of pain around all of this
and it is a normal human behavior for
that pain to
leave a scar on our psyche
and i just want to tell you out loud as
somebody just listening to you i'm not
talking to a lady that's unintelligent
you're very articulate you made your
case in a very short period of time you
got on the radio which is a
nerve-wracking thing to do
and you pulled off this conversation not
everybody can do that not everybody can
get past kelly to get on the air
i mean you did all of this today and so
i think that um
i just and i'm not i'm not you know i'm
not blowing smoke i
really do believe you are worth five to
ten times
more in the marketplace than you think
you're worth
i do believe that myself and i think we
need to develop a career path
and track that might take you a year to
get on it might take a little time
but to start to believe and take some
steps in the right direction
towards something that gets your income
way up because this government idea of
ten thousand dollars hovering over your
head
it's not like they're offering you a
hundred thousand dollars they didn't
offer you a good life they offered you
below poverty and you took it
yeah well here's the second option okay
what about going back to school
you don't necessarily have to go back to
school if if that's what it takes to go
live your dream
we'll talk about that but that's not
necessarily the magic pill
yeah the magic pill might just be the
magic pill
might i mean because let me just i'm not
suggesting you do this but let me just
give you an example the example i miss
used a minute ago you do not have to
have a college degree to sell
residential real estate
right and if you told me that was your
dream and i'm not suggesting it is but
that's an example of something where
going back to school is not necessary
now if you want to get a master's degree
in psychology because you want to do
grief counseling as a professional
counselor because you've been through
some stuff
then yeah you need to go back to school
for that so here's what we're going to
do i'm going to put you on holding and
kelly's gonna pick up we're gonna plug
you into the ken coleman stuff
we're gonna get your income up to where
this little ten thousand dollar sentence
the government is throwing you and
devaluing you with
is no longer holding you back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
well if you're in debt and you're stuck
it can feel
like you're fighting a losing battle
feels like the bills are winning
i've been there i remember you may
wonder if you're ever really going to
get ahead well i can tell you that you
can it doesn't have to be this way
when you attack this debt like your life
depends on it it starts falling back
you can take back your paycheck and
start building the life you want start
building some wealth become a baby steps
millionaire you can get there with
financial peace
university in this class you'll learn
our proven plan it's helped millions pay
off their debt fast
but you'll never make the change you
need to do unless you stick to a budget
and that's why
with this you also get the premium
version of our budgeting tool
every dollar the world's best budgeting
tool and it's all
available only with a ramsey plus
membership
financial peace university every dollar
and many other things with ramsey plus
you can get ahead start your free trial
of ramsey plus and end
this constant battle for your money text
trial
to 33 789 text trial
three seven eight nine
our question of the day comes from our
friends at blinds.com
a great american company find out for
yourself why blinds.com is the number
one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples
free shipping and when the new promos
they run all the time you'll save even
more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible
deal today's question is from gwendolyn
in connecticut i'm 21 i've got three
thousand dollars in debt which will be
paid off by
august 1. i came upon your youtube
channel i heard you talking about the
ben and arthur story
where did ben invest the money in a bank
or in the stock market
does it matter whether i put a lump sum
or a little in each month as long as
there's two thousand dollars at the end
of the month
how do i keep the money in the account
and should i pay off debt first
and can i start saving and playing
paying off that simultaneously
a lot going on here gwyndolin well i'm
glad you found us on uh youtube
so here's the thing the ben and arthur
story is not
a story or an actual game plan it is
mathematics to show you the importance
of compound interest
that's all it is it shows you the power
of compound interest it shows you how
important it is to get started early
which is a motivated use because you're
wanting to get started early so that's
perfect now then that's how that works
now what you do want to follow in order
to have the results that ben an author
had
meaning get compound interest working on
your best favor
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income until you have 10 million
dollars
and then your most powerful wealth
building tool is your wealth
it'll start making you more money than
you make you
but until you've got five to ten million
dollars you are the magic sauce kiddo
your income is the deal now the problem
is in america most people have given
their income away
to buy crap that they can't afford
that they didn't even really want to
impress people they don't even really
like
and so we have a whole bunch of
instagram freaks out here running around
deeply in debt impressing people that
they'll never meet at a stoplight
with a car that they can't afford it's
one big freaking selfie
that's what the whole thing is it's all
about presentation and not about fact
and actual
who we are we lost our soul in the
process
so the secret gwendolyn is you don't
give a crap
what other people think that starts it
right there
because that changes what you wear the
purse you carry the trips you go on
it changes the car you drive for most
people
it might change the house you live in it
might change the apartment you live in
while you're waiting to save up money to
buy a house
because if all you care about is i'm
gonna live like no one else so that
later i can live and give like no one
else it sets you up in a whole different
mindset
because see if you don't have any
payments and you've got control of your
income
now you've got money to invest and now
you've got money to be generous with
and 100 percent of the people that are
generous and invest systematically over
a given period of time become wealthy
it happens every stinking time
but most people aren't generous and most
people don't invest systematically
over a long period of time because they
give all their money
to the bank in the form of payments
buying crap that they can't afford so
we work a thing called the baby steps
it's a proven plan it's gotten
millions and millions of people out of
debt and for that matter probably made
several million millionaires
we call them baby step millionaires
because they work the baby steps
and so the first thing you do is get a
thousand dollars the second thing you do
is you pay off all your debts
listing them smallest to largest
everything but your house if you've got
a house
listing the smallest largest paying
minimum payments on everything but the
little one get rid of everything now you
don't have any payments that's a good
place to be
that's an unusual place to be that puts
you in about the top ten percent of
americans right there alone
because most people have sally mae in
their spare bedroom
most people have a car fleece
they've got a payment on the bass boat
because they needed a bigger motor those
bass were out running them
most people buy crap all the time on
payments
you're going to stop that and you're
going to get out of debt once you're
debt free everything but the house and
by the way if you do this with great
intensity
no eating out during this short period
of time no vacations during this short
period of time so that you can vacation
and eat out anywhere you want later you
live like no one else so that later you
can live and give like no one else
then you get to move on to baby step
three because you got no payments now
you're gonna build a fully funded
emergency fund a rainy day fund
you know why because it's gonna rain
dave you need to be positive
i'm positive it's going to rain you need
to be ready
it's coming life is going to happen and
you need 10
15 20 000 3 to 6 months of expenses
sitting there
to catch the crap when it comes at your
front door
and doesn't turn into new death the
transmission's going to go out your
aunt's going to die and you got to fly
to seattle i don't know what it is
something's going to come up
and you're going to need some money
suddenly
that's what an emergency is it's an
unexpected event three to six months of
expenses
now you're at twenty thousand dollars or
so cash in the bank and you don't have a
payment in the world except your house
payment how does that feel everybody say
great
great highly unusual at that point you
would be officially weird just having
gotten through those three steps
then you do baby step four start saving
15 of your income
into your retirement accounts roth iras
401ks with matches
all in good growth stock mutual funds
that have great rates of return
and in an average of 15.4 years you will
be
a baby steps millionaire meanwhile
you're saving for your kids college and
baby step five and six is you're paying
off your house the average person
following this plan pays off their house
in 10.2 years
oh these are actual numbers now
you can e listen if you want to get rich
quick you got to go somewhere else
i can't help you with get rich quick
because get rich quick is not reliable
there's no shortcut to any places worth
going no discipline seems pleasant at
the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
discipline sorry maturity
sorry see it's so easy to stand out in a
world full of people that don't have any
of that
all you gotta do is just decide you get
to decide i'm gonna do this
and you just decide no one can tell you
what to do nobody can make you do it i
can't make you do it
you know all this crap dave ramsey said
i can't dave ramsey didn't tell you you
didn't do anything you gotta do whatever
you want to do
i'm just showing you a path and if you
decide to follow that path it is the
shortest distance between where you are
and some wealth
is wealth everything good lord no i'd
rather have relationships
in health but why not go get both
they're both within your grasp
doesn't cost any extra to play the game
right
matter of fact it costs considerably
less that is the baby steps
and then once you're completely out of
that house and everything you will
become very very wealthy throughout your
life
and you'll be in a position to look over
and go
hey there's a single mom hurting i can
buy her a 3 000
car and it's like most people buying a
biscuit
because if you got three or four million
dollars and you write a 3 000 check you
don't feel it
if you have three thousand dollars and
you run a three thousand dollar check
you really feel it
see this is what wealth does it gives
you margins and
options the ability to help other people
the ability to change your family tree
that's what this is all about so
gwendolyn the answer to your question is
you follow the baby steps
and it's your shortest distance to get
to be ben and arthur
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
kirk and nikki are with us hey guys how
are you
oh we're good how are you dave welcome
where do you guys live oh my god
michigan
say again elmira michigan what is that
new year in michigan
uh gaylord okay cool good to have you
guys and you're all the way to nashville
to do a debt free scream how much have
you paid off
33 122.62
perfect how long did that take you 22
months all right
and your range of income during that two
years uh 69 000
to about 72 000. very good what do you
guys do for a living
i'm a stay-at-home mom i uh played gold
and silver for automotive
excellent very good okay and what kind
of debt was your 33 000
oh lots of stuff uh computer medical
debt
401k loan four credit cards a car and a
signature loan
just kind of normal yeah how long you
guys been married
uh 13 years today all right well happy
anniversary thank you
very cool so two years ago
a decade of marriage caught up with you
yup and said and kicked your butt and
said something's got to change tell me
the story what happened
uh well we had started sending my son to
preschool
at a private christian school and we
wanted him to continue
throughout elementary school and the
tuition goes up quite a bit once they
hit kindergarten
sure and we were looking at that and we
had to go through our budget we couldn't
afford it
wow okay so the babies
come first now what are we going to do
what'd you come up with
well about 10 years ago i had gone
through fbu with a friend
she invited me to go with her and her
husband and
i i had told him about it at the time
and he's like yeah
yeah i got it i got this you know and we
didn't
you go on i got this we don't okay so
what happened
you went back yeah yep yep i um
after we went through the budget and i
was like you know if we didn't have all
this debt
we could afford to send the kids to
private school
and then i brought it up again i was
like
please please take this class with me it
took a little bit of convincing but so i
got on board how did she get you to do
it
just asking me you know just showing me
the numbers you know she i need some
help
well she she literally put a whole
together whole spreadsheet
of everything that we had you know if we
paid this off this is what happens
you know this is how much we need for
this for the kids at school
you know and i got on board it it made
sense yeah
he was he was so she used like facts to
convince you yeah
okay that works yeah i like that one
that's a good plan
because you weren't obstinate you just
said i thought we were okay and then she
looks at and goes oh this is not fun
i'm with you let's fix this okay so then
you go to financial peace university
what was the first thing you learned in
there that you went oh my
um just really about how to manage the
debt you know
seeing that once you put it on paper
it's a lot different than just
you know saying oh i got this much i'll
pay this much this month
once you actually put it on paper and
look at how much you're spending
yeah and just in debt it's a real
eye-opener really it really is it blows
you
you feel like where's all that money
going right
yep yeah yeah what are you gonna say
uh nikki uh well i was actually just
gonna say
that part of our story was that we had
ten thousand dollars
in debt that i wasn't aware of uh-oh
yeah and we talked about this beforehand
i'm not throwing them under the bus but
part of the other part of that story was
that i didn't know
what was going on because i wasn't
participating oh
okay so when really he hid it from you
he just didn't tell you right yeah okay
yep so
i mean once we started working together
as a team everything changed
wow okay and that that takes the
pressure off of you kirk
it does it's like oh okay let's do this
together and then
you know because one of the things i i
told sharon was you're going to help me
make these decisions that way if they're
wrong you can't say i told you so
yeah she she's my rock on this you know
um her being a stay-at-home mom
you know she does so much more than just
being a stay at home oh sure
you know it's a home economist yeah it
is you know and you know i go to work
but she honestly does more work than i
do you know
you know kids are tough but you know
kids are growing up beautifully and
very loved yeah so that's good stuff
well done
so what do you tell people the secret to
getting out of that is for us
teamwork yeah teamwork once we started
working as a team
everything changed yeah everything's on
the table all cards are face up and then
we say all right let's do the plan and
we're doing it together yep yeah and
discipline you know once you start it
you know stick with it because it's hard
it's very easy to fall off and
you know but as if you are dedicated to
it you can
get through it really easy what was the
hardest point
where you almost run out of steam during
the 22 months where were you when you
kind of like i'm out of breath
covered really oh really yeah yeah
because
i i got i got laid off yeah luckily it
only ended up being
four weeks but we got laid off we were
you know i was like okay let's go into
cash com
our cash conversation mode yeah you know
and shortly after that my car broke
you know and it's just like so that's
like this time last year yeah
yeah like june or may or something yep
yeah yeah you know
so yeah we got and we got tested like
right after we started going on the
program our septic
went out of course of course yeah but
yeah yeah
covered the car breaks the septic goes
out it's like murphy shows up
yeah but yeah we cash flowed it we sold
a camper
to pay for the septic system that's when
i knew he was in
yeah yeah that was my baby that's a big
deal
yeah so losing the camper is a big thing
but the septic system working is kind of
essential
for sure yeah wow you guys that that's
uh
that's real stuff because really what
that's saying is about halfway through
right
yeah just when you got smacked in the
mouth and you had to reset
and go okay are we doing this if we're
doing this the camper's got to go
if we're doing this then i got to do
this and we got to do that and we got to
conserve cash like you said and
and a lot of people were facing that at
this time last year a lot of people and
you guys
you guys found a way to work through it
and and here you are the other side
victorious yes feels pretty good to work
through it doesn't it oh
so good yeah yeah how's it feel to have
no payments awesome
have you ever been debt-free in your
marriage ever no no so 13 years was the
first time
yeah and your anniversary presents yes
i'm so proud of y'all
thank you cool and you brought the
kiddos with you to do the debt-free
screams yeah you come up what are their
names and ages
cole he's six and courtney just turned
four
okay and you brought some cheerleaders
with you in the in the gallery here
who's with you
uh my mom tangi and my dad david well
they got to be proud of y'all too
yes our biggest cheerleaders that's good
that's good you gotta have those we got
a copy of the legacy journey for you
that's your next uh chapter you're on
your way to baby steps millionaires now
move on to changing your whole family
tree very good stuff
and a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away get somebody else
started as you keep talking about this
because you can't shut up about it once
you do it it's good stuff
it's good stuff so have uh cole and
courtney been practicing
they have they all the way from michigan
they know they're debt-free scream
oh yeah and they know what's about to
come up well you change their tree
you change their family tree you guys
are heroes we're so proud of you
as honor to know you very very well done
your mom and dad are proud of you it's
good stuff
very good stuff kirk and nicki cole and
courtney from michigan
33 000 paid off in 22 months
in the middle of coving 69 to 72 000
income
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i'm not sure
courtney's old enough but cole may be
old enough to remember that
weird time his parents came to that
weird place down in tennessee and they
stood on the stage and they screamed
i'm debt-free
and when cole
is 90 and telling his great-grandkids
the story
of his mom and dad changing their family
tree
that's pretty powerful stuff you guys
that was the sound you heard you could
hear
cole's voice screaming over that
microphone
that was the sound of a family tree
being changed mom and dad are heroes
they did what it takes to go win in a
culture where everybody tells you that
the government is going to fix your life
where you're a victim of this or a
victim of that
[Music]
not kirk and nikki not them
way to go guys this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america we're
so glad you are here
this is the ramsey show carlos is with
us in los angeles hi carlos how are you
hey dave thank you for taking my call my
long time listening first time caller
honored to have you how can we help
so um my wife and i and our family we've
been working baby steps for about five
years now
and um we're currently on baby step 3b
and on baby step four
um so we have about two hundred thousand
dollars saved for down payment here in
los
angeles but you know that the market's
pretty ridiculous here
and the mortgage will not be a fourth of
our take home
but we can't find a mortgage of our
fourth of our take home um
if we buy uh mortgages that we're
looking for so one of the things we do
have is we have
some out-of-state rentals i know how you
feel about how to save rentals but we
bought them before the program
and we like the real estate aspect of it
we owe
mortgages on both we have 80 000 that we
owe on one
and 90 on the other my wife and i are
thinking of pausing
um they to 3b and just hitting with
gazelle intensity for the next two to
three years
and pay off the rentals which will
increase our
cash flow or our monthly income that
will then allow us
to meet the guidelines for the fourth
that we're taking because we don't want
a 30-year mortgage and we're not trying
to fall into stupid
okay we definitely want to kind of make
sure we follow the program good that's a
good one
there's nothing wrong with that um how
much equities in the properties could
you just sell them and use that to meet
your goal
well we we we do have substantial equity
we do have about it's about
200 each we have 200 thousand dollars of
victory in each house
um but one of the things our long-term
goal is within 15 years we want to paid
for
the primary residence and we have we do
like the residential
uh real estate aspect of it we don't
like the state that we
uh currently are in as far as rentals
because this doesn't work for us the
numbers are ridiculous and
and actually we i thought of your sunk
cost analysis about
putting you know the money that were on
the table would i purchase these homes
they actually
purchased these homes with their
intention of renting them out and
they've been pretty
good so we've been lucky i know um if
you want to go that way that's okay i'm
not going to be mad at you if you want
to go that way
okay but i mean another option is
obviously selling those and that would
give you the money to buy a home today
yeah the other thing we thought should
with the cash or should we with the
money
to pay off the rental should we invest
the money no short term
office guys just pay them off just pay
them off as fast as you can
both of them pay them off yes you have
what now say it again
we have 200 200 000 that we have saved
should we just pay them off now and then
rebuild our down payment again because
yeah
cash flow yes yeah all right that's what
you're wanting to do you're wanting to
use these rental cash flow to be able to
buy a house
and does 200 pay both of them off uh yes
we would actually have
um yeah it's 170 that we owe on the
total mortgage balance yeah
okay and then use that use that increase
cash flow and everything else in your
budget to go back to baby step 3b then
actually you're technically a baby step
7 if you want to be technical about it
because you're debt free
until you go buy a house right right but
it doesn't matter either way you're
going to pile up as much cash out of the
cash flow of the rentals and everything
else to build your down payment and then
go by
and that's exactly what i would do
franklin is in
richland washington hi franklin how are
you
how are you mr dave good how can i help
well i am on baby step 2 with my
wonderful wife
and uh all i've got left is my student
loan debt was about
thirty thousand and got a bit of bad
news i
just got a terminal cancer diagnosis six
to twelve months
oh my so
i am a 17 year old a six-year-old
and a three-year-old how old are you i
am 35.
oh my god have you gotten a second
opinion yet
i do and it's not good it's esophageal
cancer and it's
really quick and it's really uh one of
the worst ones you can get
franklin i'm so sorry
how's um how's mom doing your wife
um i'm scared to tell her so far yeah
i just found out this morning oh my i've
known for nine years it would be a
possibility
because i had the pre-cancerous
condition but now i'm kind of heading
home
and my wife is a wonderful woman but
she's the
the spender free spirit and
she comes to our monthly budget meetings
every month
and she let me know what she wants but
i'm still in charge of making sure all
the bills are paid how do i help set her
up
i do have about 45 000 in 401
and about 500 in life insurance
well we're gonna surround you guys and
walk with you and help you okay
uh there's a lot of moving parts to this
um
and it's uh everybody's scared and
everybody's emotional and
and it's all valid um so
um uh
you you called and asked and so i'm
gonna be cold and calculated in spite of
how much that's why i need uncle dave
today
instead of in spite of how much i have a
lump in my throat right now okay
um number one student loans uh
uh if you don't survive uh they they go
away
so you don't pay another dime on the
student loan
okay so the government's going to eat
this student loan
if the if the diagnosis should have
about 50 000 in mortgage balance okay if
the
if the prognosis is correct the student
loan is just going to go away
and she there's a process she goes
through to file with a death certificate
and so forth
and when you become when you pass away
or you are permanently disabled student
loans are forgiven
that is one of the times they are
actually forgiven um
so anyway uh we can help you with that
help her
with that process and when the time
comes but in the meantime we're not
going to use any of your money for that
uh we're going to use your money for you
to uh have a quality of life
and the quality of life includes time
with your family that's there there is
no point in working on a debt snowball
there's no point in doing anything right
now except just conserving cash
like i said we were almost all the way
done with baby step two
and all i had left was just two months
and you don't have that anymore
because i just took it off the table
okay and so
now what we've got to deal with is uh
get her
trained with money where she's confident
to carry this household while she's
walking through this diagnosis and
prognosis with you okay
okay because the more confident she is
the easier would it be
to go through the class again absolutely
and we're going to pay for it it's on us
okay i'm going to put you i think i'm
going to put you into ramsey plus and
we're going to hook you up with one of
our financial coaches
uh there in washington that'll walk with
you as our gift
we're not you're not going to charge you
a dime for any of this okay and
i want her to have some people in her
corner
and you got an amazing support network
and you what i'm talking about on the
financial piece okay
and so you watching her become confident
will be helpful to you agreed
yes sir if she becomes competent with
money and confident that's going to help
you with this process as well
okay so you're in a good church you said
you had an amazing support group
we have a good family support network
yes okay good
good well obviously you're gonna get
spiritual things arranged in your life
as well agreed
yes sir okay and um
so uh we're gonna get her trained uh
you've got
she will have if this prognosis is
correct she'll have 500
000 coming to her um and
uh it would be okay for you guys to have
already planned out what to do with that
before before she gets it um and i'll
recommend that you you said the mortgage
balance was what
right around fifty thousand now i
recommend we pay that off and then we've
got 450 right
and so you know what the plan is and and
she executes that plan she's going to be
okay because she's
competent and confident and we've got a
plan
if i'm in your shoes this is how my
brain is working i
i will feel better if the people i'm
leaving are going to have a
are going to be taken care of and that's
why you're calling and that's all that's
been going through my mind today yeah
i can imagine
okay and so uh the the last piece of
that then is you meet with
um as you've got the strength and are
able to do it all and you feel
you get past these things you meet with
a smart vester pro
so i'm going to put you on hold and
kelly's going to hook you with a coach
with a smart investor pro and financial
piece
and ramsey plus financial peace
university and we're gonna walk with
both of you
and you tell your sweet wife we're
praying for both of you and we are here
whatever she needs whatever questions
she's got
along the way whatever questions you've
got along the way we're gonna walk with
you guys and keep our arms around you
i'm so sorry franklin
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host this is your show
america we're glad you are here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five kayla is with us
in detroit michigan kicking off this
hour hi kayla how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so i'm 23. i just moved out
um like a couple months ago i'm on baby
step one
and my question is is that i'm trying to
um cut down from my budget to save money
and i volunteer for a non-profit
organization
that i truly love doing but it requires
i it requires me to travel twice a year
out of my own expenses and i was
wondering if i should
keep going um with it or if
um because i need i'm trying to get debt
free i'm wondering if i should uh
um turn down my position yeah what what
are you doing with a non-profit what is
it
um i'm a treasurer and um
basically we help around the metro
detroit area with uh sobriety
well that's good okay and what drew you
to work in that
um i'm three and a half years sober good
for you
well thank you well done so what were
you on what what what
what kind of substance um
everything but mostly xanax and alcohol
okay
all right well i'm proud of you very
well done
um thank you so what does the travel
involve all around the detroit area you
said that doesn't sound like travel
um uh no like out of state twice a year
okay so you have to go represent your
local chapter
as the treasurer at a convention
okay is that mandatory for you to
continue to do the other work that
you're doing in the area
um it's more like peer pressure
yeah um i know like really help out if i
went
yeah yeah okay um and what do you make
what's your income
um i just got my dream career as an
electrical apprentice then i make
after taxes a little over 30 000.
okay and when will you finish your
apprenticeship
i'm in about four and a half years okay
and what will you be making then
uh over ninety thousand good for you
it's a good track you got
you got a good you got a good life laid
out for yourself well done
and you moved out of the house and here
we go right game on
yeah game on it got it just got real
yeah
okay um
[Applause]
um and how much debt do you have
about 13 13
500. okay and so you're working 40 hours
a week
yes um and then i was about to after
in september i was gonna work part-time
at a gas station
to save up for like christmas presents
and extra
um stuff i don't want to budget out for
okay that'd be fine or maybe you can
find something that's even a little more
lucrative for your part time than that
because if you're going to go the
trouble to work part time i want you to
make some money
right um yeah and so i don't know what
it is necessarily but
um you might think about even uh
i don't know dog sitting or nanny or
whatever that kind of stuff in the
evenings
and you you actually can make a lot more
doing that than you could doing
something else so just be thoughtful
about that
so and and in listening to your story
um i want to participate
in with my advice i want to participate
in your
in your the 33 year old version of you
really winning
that's how i'm thinking about this okay
and so
uh if i'm here and hearing what i'm
hearing your number one goal and i know
you agree with this
is continued sobriety because if you
don't have that everything else falls
apart agreed
yes so to the extent that this volunteer
position
with the sobriety organization
is helping you in your sobriety walk i
don't want to cut it down
like for instance i would never tell you
to work a part-time job and miss an aaa
meeting
uh you would because the aaa meeting is
more important for your future
long term than the part-time job would
be that's an example by prioritizing
your sobriety over other over money
stuff you follow me
yeah i have worked too hard to take to
go back in there yeah and so what i
would do if i were you is i would
analyze
is there a way i can volunteer
uh for one year work a good strong
part-time job
and uh is there a different way i can
volunteer for one year
and still be involved in the sobriety
community that you're plugged into
because as you've already as you've
always okay as you've already discovered
there's a lot of ways to
but communities valid it's a big deal
for all of us but it's a really big deal
for you three years dry
yeah yeah so are you going to meetings
still
yes okay and so that will affect your
schedule on part-time
agreed um i can find other times
to go i know but i mean you can't you
can't work every night for six hours
oh no okay that's what i mean because
i'm not afraid to push you to work girl
because if you got rid of 13 000 in debt
and had an extra 10 000
worth of income mathematically it helps
your whole situation agreed
yes that's what i'm trying to get you to
but i don't want to do that and
interfere
with your walk here because because
here's the thing if we
if we got you making 90 000 a year by by
september
and it costs you your sobriety it's
going to cost you all that money it's
because your money's gonna go away so
your job shows your life
because you're you know so lack of
sobriety eats all of that up it kills it
all it trumps it
so you you already know that but i'm
just i'm saying it out loud i know it
too
okay so all of that to say
uh i want you to stay volunteering
somehow but the faster you can get this
debt off of you
and you can raise your income a little
bit while doing that
while staying plugged into that
community uh
the the less stress you're gonna have in
your life
and i thought i heard you say xanax yeah
yeah
okay so i i like getting stressed out of
your life agreed
yes and money money debt and and tight
budget living on your own for the first
time in a long time is
is stress and we don't need that here
either so that's that's an enemy to your
sobriety
in your case too so i think you're doing
great i think you're a rock star i think
you're absolutely going to win
uh but let's balance between the extra
income we can create and getting the
money stress off
versus staying plugged into making sure
you're going to meetings and plugged
into this
the sobriety community that you love and
that you're volunteering with that saved
your life
okay so maybe you're not the treasurer
for a year though
maybe you're something else that stays
home
okay does that make sense does that make
sense
am i hearing you to put all these pieces
together right did i miss something
oh no i think you're pretty incredible
i think you're going to do some big
stuff you fought one of the biggest
battles people
can fight and you did it before you're
23 pretty incredible
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switched to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching
to pure top just go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
thank you for joining us america this is
the ramsey show if you hadn't noticed
the cost of college has gotten
real ridiculous serious dollars
especially at a four-year university and
even more so at like one of these
expensive private colleges
you need a plan if you're gonna pay for
college
you need a plan scholarships and
financial aid
they go a long way but you need an esa
you need a savings plan
a 529 for your kid and we can show you
how to do that
investing in good growth stock mutual
funds and do it throughout their life
you'll have enough to send them to
school and you need to learn about these
different accounts and what the
strengths are and the weaknesses are of
each one
and you need somebody in your corner to
help get it all set up it's called a
smart fester pro
you're the smart investor the pro helps
you do it
and the smart smartvestor pros are
people that we endorse they do not work
for us
they do a great job of guiding you and
your 529 your esa getting your kids
college set up
getting your roth ira set up if you need
to or doing a 401k roll over if you need
to
go to ramsey solutions dot com
slash smart vester ramsey solutions dot
com slash smart investor you can click
the smart vester button anywhere
on our site and be sure you get
connected with it'll drop down a list of
the ones in your area you pick which one
you want to go to
or you can talk to all of them and
interview them and decide but you're
going to be meeting with someone that
has the heart of a teacher
that's going to guide you and teach you
not do it for you
you're not going to say i don't know
what my investments are my guy handles
it
we don't allow that you have to be like
a grown-up and you have to know what the
crap you're doing
and that means somebody's gonna guide
you and teach you and you're gonna
know what you're doing you're gonna
understand
what you're doing or you don't do it
david is with us in providence
rhode island hi david welcome to the
ramsey show
dave what's up man hey man how can i
help
talk to you about 15 months ago changed
my life
wow um i have a yeah yeah
um i have i have two questions for you
um one you always talk about the fleece
i have no idea well i know what elise is
but i have no idea what a police is
so when you say that what are you
referring to
well that's a country boy's attempt at
humor when you uh
when you fleece a sheep you cut his hair
off
and it's a country saying it's a country
saying that means you got screwed over
and what that means is a a lease is a
fleece a lease is a bad deal that's what
that means
all right so i own and this is part of
that question um
i own a business and i do fleece a car
for uh my wife uh the company has
plenty of money to pay for that i know
you disagree with it was it still a bad
idea if it's the rule of business
sure sure it's just a it's an
alternative it's an expensive method of
financing is all it is
you're renting you're you're renting a
car
for your wife and you're paying a rental
fee that's the lease
payment and the rental fee at the end of
the lease you can either buy that car or
turn it in
right correct okay so if you were to
take a financial calculator
and sit down with a financial person
that would show you how to do the entry
into the financial calculator and you
entered in the stream of payments the
monthly payments that you're doing
over the length of the lease and you
enter in the final amount you would pay
for it
versus what the sticker value on the car
is
you will find that on average they are
charging you 14.2
interest that's what i mean by it's a
screw job
but it's never it's never disclosed and
the reason it's not disclosed as a
actual interest rate is because you
haven't technically borrowed money
you're just renting the car
but you can back out the financials on
it and determine what they're charging
you
for the money which is essentially
what's happening right there you're
borrowing the money essentially you're
paying car
payment right right yeah yeah and so
it's
on average about 14 now some are lower
some are higher but that's the average
nationally
and that's why smart money magazine dave
ramsey and anybody else who's done the
calculations on this stuff say it's the
most expensive way
to operate a vehicle so if you uh if you
want to buy your wife a car
you should pay cash
working on it okay so let's you know
what i do is figure out a way to get out
of this lease either get it sold or get
it paid off
if you can come up with the cash just
pay it off you want to keep the car
that's okay with me
but i wouldn't sit there and rent their
money for 14
and that's what borrowed money is it's
renting money and in a sense that's what
the car
lease is and since you're getting
screwed we call it a
fleece you're getting fleeced if you
ever hear someone david say that you got
fleeced it means you got messed over
that's what it means uh tani or tony is
with us
in uh tani is with us in atlanta hi tani
how are you
hey dave how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
um i wanted to get your advice on um i
have a good bit of debt that i've been
working on
um i'll be getting married soon and i'm
thinking about leaving my job
i'm dependent on at my job but i've been
offered a what i think is a great
opportunity but i'm feeling guilty
but trying to make this decision um i am
okay so what do you mean
what do you make now i make 85 000. what
would you make of the new job
120 000. okay and so you get this
substantial raise
yes and what have you done wrong if you
take this job that you're feeling guilty
about
um my company is going to be moving and
i'm the controller and i've been
involved heavily on
start-up calls and making sure that we
can make this move
and make a fun make it in a financially
sound way
and we're weeks away from the move and
so if i leave
yeah um i feel really guilty about it
when are you required to take the new
job
august 4th so in two weeks
they'll be in two weeks and the move is
when
um september the middle of september
middle of august middle of august middle
of august
yeah okay how do you ask your new
employer if you could have a middle of
august start date
no i have not your new employer
no i haven't asked them that rigid or do
they want you that they want you badly
they want me bad they said they need me
to start as soon as possible
so i'm hours away from putting in that
notice
well ultimately you would take the job
okay
okay but i'm with you i i think you're
you've got a matter of conscience here
you
you're a person of responsibility and um
they're counting on you and you don't
want to let them down and i
i think that's a i think that's a if you
were applying
here and you came in and and we wanted
to hire you
we would say gosh we really need you but
you know what we admire what you're
saying so much that that means you're
going to bring that same
character to work here that we now we
really want you
and so we'll give you to august 15. okay
if i were your future employer i would
admire you
if you came in and said i can come
august first but i really really
really feel like i'm letting these
people down is there any way i could
start a little bit later to help them
with their move
okay i haven't thought of that so that
could be something
don't you think if you were the future
employer you would like to see that
yeah i would type a person yeah
definitely
and the other other option of course is
that you offer to work
uh for free for your former employer
uh at night and weekends
to help to help them make the move you
give them
you could give them 40 or 80 hours over
the next two weeks
first two weeks of august uh off hours
okay and that way you're not letting
them down but
if if you have to but um you know and i
don't know
uh i mean we have accounting is very
very important and finance is obviously
very important at ramsey
uh and we've got actually got some
positions open right now
but we don't have any of them that are
the whole place is going to fold up and
not work if you don't get here in two
weeks
okay i don't have any emergencies like
that now they may they may be in a real
tight spot the future employer
um but it sounds like you need to take
the job but we just got to work around
you feeling good about your integrity
yeah
that's what it is yeah you're a good
lady you're a good lady they're ha
they're both lucky to have you
on their team not a lot of people think
that way most people think about what
they can get out of instead of what they
can bring
you're a person who adds value there are
takers and there are givers
you get to decide which one you want to
be we all know what christy is
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes
you are the next greatest generation
because you
have proven that even in adversity that
you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
so
[Music]
thanks for joining us america in the
lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt-free stage trey is with us
hey trey how are you
i'm great how are you dave better than i
deserve sir where do you live
i currently live in baltimore maryland
i'm originally from frederick maryland
cool good to have you in nashville and
all the way here to do a debt
free screen yeah how much do you pay off
um paid off around 43 000
in 27 months good for you and your range
of income during that time
started at 37 and recently just switched
to a new job by making around 70.
whoa nice to double the income yeah what
do you do
um right now i'm a cx associate for a
media company so i basically run like
split tests on websites to see what
helps sales and conversions what were
you doing before i was a translation
project manager for like a local family
translation company
um but your i.t skills got you the
double huh
yeah yeah you could say that um i
studied psychology so it helped a lot to
kind of learn statistics and
apply that scientific foundation back
into my work so very good
good for you man well done how old are
you i'm 24.
good and what kind of debt was the 43
000
uh so 33 um was student loans
uh and then the other around 10 and a
half was a car loan
okay cool yeah so um 24 years old
27 months ago you were 21 years old
and uh you decided to get out of debt
tell me your story what happened
yeah well uh to be honest it started
with that first job
um it just wasn't really the right fit
for me um it was kind of a paper pushing
job just felt pretty miserable
and then on top of that i mean back then
i definitely had a spending problem
because
i was paying the minimums on my student
loans it was like maybe a hundred
dollars and i thought that was like the
end of the world
so um from there i just kind of started
researching budgeting um how to
switch jobs make more money and that's
that's obviously how i
i found you so me and my co-worker kind
of became
obsessed with your show uh binged all
the
all the shows on spotify so wow yeah
way to go spotify yeah well we're
honored thank you very much
i'm excited that that uh that you can do
all this in your 24 you have the rest of
your life to live without any death
that's pretty cool
yeah yeah the math is amazing of where
you're going to be
i mean you are really on a track here
this is pretty incredible
very fun so uh how many of your friends
were cheering you on and how many of
them are making fun of you
oh so i have a friend here today her
name is natalie
she's amazing she has been there from
the start
but eventually eventually i feel like my
friends kind of
i feel like i talked the ear off a
little bit with money so i kind of had
to turn to
a different community so i started
actually like doing the youtube thing
uploading videos about how to uh talk to
your employer to
raise your income how to switch jobs if
you want to um
yeah so it's called by nine to five but
essentially i just talk about all of my
uh well my journey and how it started
really with you um
in your journey so oh yeah very thankful
to have found you
well i'm honored i'm honored i'm honored
i was there to
to give you some guidance and you're a
hero man you took control of this
and uh good to have friends like natalie
around huh oh yeah literally the best
could not have done it without her yeah
very cool good stuff brother good stuff
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
um i would say start with a list of your
values
um understand how your money situation
is
or your employment situation is keeping
you from
having those values be what you live by
every single day and i think
that kind of starts your why launches
that
and then after that it's really just
budgeting like start your zero-based
budget go on every dollar
um if you're good with excel go on there
make your own just
do what you need to do to be able to
actually
track all of your income and then all of
your expenses and as long as your y is
there you should be able to
keep going um push forward so so you're
a single guy you don't have to talk
anybody into doing this except the guy
in the mirror
exactly and yeah but you had to talk him
into it for 27 months
right what was the hardest part um i
would say the hardest part was probably
like well honestly during the pandemic
uh when there was nothing to do all day
that's when i turned to the creative
side and started
telling people about my story i think
that's what helped
a lot but yeah i think the hardest part
is
just not having an immediate support
system
which covid definitely amplified sure
sure community is what we need and it's
what was taken away from us
um connectivity and uh relationships was
taken
we're damaged and taken away from us
during that time it's very hard for
folks
well very well done so the home that you
grew up in uh were they financially
responsible
or you had to learn all this from the
ground up um
i i had to learn it from you but uh
not all bad advice there um just
a lot of uh not really understanding who
i was first i think led me to make
decisions that
ultimately got me into debt um i'm very
happy that i went to college but i think
i would have done it maybe a little bit
differently if i had known
what i know now about money and the
value of education so
um yeah don't blame any of my upbringing
um on that situation and it's actually
been really awesome because
i have actually me and my parents have
talked a lot about
um just money in general and it's it's
so sweet they're saying that i inspire
them so
we're all learning together yeah that's
good very cool
very cool that is sweet and uh it's not
unusual for a sharp young man like you
to get your parents attention
so very well done sir well we're proud
of you here man
well done good job good job we got a
copy of the legacy journey for you
because that's the next chapter in your
story to completely change your whole
legacy now
and uh of course a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give away and
bless someone else
and natalie thanks for coming down and
joining him that's good stuff
all right trey from rockville maryland
43
000 paid off in 27 months making 37 to
70.
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one i'm debt-free
[Music]
this is how it's done right here baby
okay do you wanna do a little math we
could do a little math let's pretend
that you're 24 and you make 70 000
a year and you don't have a payment in
the world and you actually know how to
control money
because you're actually being a grown up
do you know how rich he's gonna be oh my
god
i mean if he just take okay let's just
say he say 15
of his income do you understand if he
does
nothing else from 24
to 64. and so he never makes any more
money than he makes now
he goes 40 years without a raise
which would officially make him a loser
i mean you can't go 40 years without a
raise right
so 40 years without a raise and he only
saves 15 percent of his income
do you understand that that amount going
into his 401 k
into his roth iras 15 of 70 000
is somewhere between seven and ten
million dollars
you're looking at a rich guy that's what
you're looking at
a future baby steps millionaire uh all
because he just changed his whole
mindset
about not only his income his values
addressing his values at work addressing
them into his budget
and making the decision to do this very
sharp young man
very sharp so that's what sets you up
guys
and uh you know then what what screws
all of that up is life
you come along and you go oh well i
don't need to do this anymore ah well i
didn't mess up maybe i didn't really
understand maybe
yeah you understood you just you don't
fall off the wagon
so you know the cool thing is if you get
this young like that
the point is the the amount of money and
you understand how
unlikely it is that you never get a
raise in 40 years
and he's in it it's in technology so
come on i mean seriously if he stays up
on his
continues to grow in his skills his
income's probably going to double in
five years
or sooner but that's if we don't do that
if we just stay at 70.
so the truth is if he just
saves 15 of his income his real income
what it really ends up being
for the balance of his life that young
man should be in the 10 to 20 million
range that's accurate without any
drama without any craziness only fifteen
percent of his income
and along the way bazaar house and pays
it off along the way
maybe he gets married and has a car pays
cash for it
along the way pays cash for kids college
along the way you can do a lot of stuff
while you're saving 15
he's still gonna end up there boom
so impressive this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 13 3
those who guard their lips
preserve their lives but those who speak
rashly
will come to ruin francis bacon said
silence is the sleep that nourishes
wisdom silence is powerful i would give
you an example of it but it's really bad
radio
in this business we call it dead air but
dead air
is a good thing in a normal conversation
it's a good thing silence is the sleep
that nourishes
wisdom uh some people talk
and uh like i said i don't have an
option here i got three hours i got to
cover right but
some people talking talking talking
christy doesn't do that christie's on
the line has a question she's in st
louis hi christy how are you hi james
how are you
better than i deserve what's up in your
world
well we have a potential change coming
to our family we own our home
and my husband uh they may be
his job may be moving us overseas for
two to three years
and our question is given the current
housing market
should we rent knowing that we would
come back here
afterwards it's kind of a rotation
should we rent our home
or sell it huh
well the um the downside
of renting it is that it is
i've done this okay um and i didn't move
back in but
the home that we lived in before our
current home is one of my rental
properties today
and i'm
i've owned rental property for 30 years
okay so i'm
like a professional landlord so it
shouldn't bother me but i'm just going
to warn you it's emotional
when you go back to your old house and
it has had a renter in it
it just it's just emotional
because even if they were the best
runner in the world they didn't take
care of your house
the way you would have yeah does that
make sense
i drove by my house i drove by my house
that i owned the other day
and i thought i think i'm gonna have to
buy the lawn care
because i can't stand those bushes
looking like that that's me you know
what i'm saying
yeah it's that kind of stuff it's like
your kid's bedroom ooh look what they
did
you know that kind of thing now you can
do it but i want you to be prepared for
the negative emotions that are going to
go with this this is not just a
financial decision because it's your
home
then it's not your home and then you're
going to come back in and you're going
to spend
a pretty serious amount of money making
it your home again
well and that was what we were thinking
because you make pretty good money
overseas and then coming back we thought
well we'll set first we're thinking
we'll sell it then we'll just
you know find another place to live when
we come back
i'm a little fearful i'm not sure
there's a housing
shortage or something no i don't think
there's a matter of fact i think it'll
be a better market for you to buy in two
years from now
or three years from now because i mean
i've never seen the market in 35 years
or 40 years in the real estate business
i got my license in 1978.
i've never seen it this hot ever so i
mean but it shouldn't last
more than three years that's right i
don't think it will it's good it's
coveted and supply demand
related is what's driving the now i
don't doubt that the market will be
strong but this white hot
craziness where you get 27 offers on a
house in 48 hours stuff
uh i think that'll be gone and you can
take advantage of that right now and get
one of these crazy people to give you
crazy money right
yeah well that's what we like to do yeah
and you know and it sounds like you're
not
married emotionally to this house
we don't love it okay let's sell it
okay and just get you a nice good one
when you come back in two to three years
and use all this you know use some of
the income to pile up to move up
in-house maybe
yeah that's a great idea yeah and uh
what will it sell for
well we were gonna try for five
okay so you won't have any you won't
have any capital gains because married
filing jointly up to
500 000 of gain is tax free on your
primary residence oh nice okay so you
any money you make on this house is free
and clear along with the money you make
you pay taxes on overseas
but um you know you'll pile all of that
money up and you'll come back with this
bankroll
to do another deal and you'll get a
house you like a lot more
all right well thanks i feel better
about this
yeah that's what i would do if i were in
your shoes listening to your story
so what's your husband do um well he
works
for boeing um yeah and so they like to
move people around every now and then so
okay
good very cool very cool yeah well hey
thank you for joining us
and you guys have it sounds like a great
adventure have a great adventure that's
cool
katie is in houston hi katie welcome to
the ramsey show
hi thank you sure what's up
well um we're on baby step five
and are thinking of selling our house
and buying an rv to travel with our new
baby
and i thought i could get your thoughts
on this i have a couple things i'm
worried about
and wanted to know what you thought what
are you worried about
well um i'm worried about paying for my
name
i'm sorry i didn't hear you you cut out
you're worried about what
sorry paying capital gains you won't
have any capital
gains what is your home what is your
home worth
well it's not that it's i haven't owned
it for two years
oh okay well yeah you will um have you
have you owned it for one year
yes okay you will have capital gains not
ordinary income
so what will be your profit
well um i own 60 000 on it
what did you pay for the house 225. what
would it sell for
i think 260. you won't have any heart i
mean
by the time you you sell the house for
260 and you have expenses you're not
going to make much right
and so let's pretend that let's pretend
that you had 15 000
of expenses okay that means you're gonna
have a gain
of twenty thousand dollars at a fifteen
percent
capital gains rate that's six thousand
dollars whoopty dumpty
okay that's not that's not a reason to
not make this decision
now what is the deal with the rv and a
baby
that sounds like hell to me
you might be right um it sounds like a
good time
because he's not in school and
honestly as a former kindergarten
teacher i feel like i can
plant the basics for him and he's
he's mobile he's easy now in fact you
can probably hear him in the background
he'll be nine months
uh on wednesday yeah and so what does
your husband do for a living
uh my wife is a police officer okay all
right
and how are you going to be living in an
rv and the police officer show up for
work
well you're not going to be rving all
over the country you're going to be
parked
we're going to be parked for the
majority of a month and then
on the weekends of texas we have lots of
options of where to go
for short-term weekend trips and then
during the summer and during holidays
she's in a position where she can take
an extended week or two weeks
here and there and so this it's kind of
a five-year plan
for us
okay um you can do what you want to do
it's your life okay uh but you made the
mistake of calling me
and i'm an expert on my opinion so i'll
give you that that's why i called
so i'll give you that that capital gains
are not a problem here the rv goes down
in value
it's a really bad idea to buy an rv for
the plan that you have because you're
going to lose your butt on that thing
during this two year period of time
you'd be better off to rent one
occasionally like the two week or three
week period of time when you've got some
time off
to go and rent and go to a go rv and let
someone else take the butt kicking on
the depreciation
because the things are hard to get rid
of once you own them
and you'll lose your you're going to
lose your you're going to lose your butt
on it
um and what do you think about renting
it i'm sorry
i mean renting it just for that short
period of time on the weekends and stuff
if you want to rent an occasional thing
but i think you keep your house and let
it go up in value
and have a nice quality place during the
week to live in
instead of living in a tin can with a
baby
well we were thinking about renting it
when we weren't using it
yeah that's a really bad idea you got
liability out the butt the thing's gonna
lose you're gonna lose your tail on this
you can do it whatever you wanna do but
i i gotta tell you if i were you
i would enjoy some of those times away
that you're wanting to do and spend my
money in different ways rather than
losing it on an rv
and i think you'll have a higher quality
of life especially during the week
doing that i would keep that house if i
were in your shoes
you do whatever you want though that
puts us hour the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
you